[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and we're thrilled to have you here
we're so excited about what the future
holds and we've invested a lot to make
you successful with Google Cloud so you
can build applications faster and more
secure than ever
you may have heard Thomas kurian talk
about how we offer prescriptive Guidance
with an opinionated approach to solve
developer velocity challenges in today's
session I'm going to show you how
exactly we do this by highlighting how
Google Cloud lets you deliver secure
applications in an open manner even
though working remotely has become the
norm working faster remotely and across
distributed teams continues to be a
challenge typical friction points
include onboarding Road employees
setting up Dev and test environments and
long build times just to name a few
when it comes to security code and data
exfiltration risks are key
this is especially true in sensitive and
regulative environments
customers tell us that current solutions
to secure Dev environments can add
developer friction to the experience
for example streaming-based Solutions
May introduce unwanted latency
in running your specific containers may
not be fully supported
solving developer velocity challenges
requires a two-pronged approach
how do we not only make it easier for
developers to build applications but
also easy for it admins to securely
scale in Dev environments
to address this
I'm excited to announce the availability
of cloud workstations
think of cloud workstations as providing
pre-configured but customizable
developer environments in the cloud with
your favorite dev tools pre-installed
and up to date
Cloud workstations come with multi-ide
support such as IntelliJ Pi charm Ryder
sea lion code OSS and others as part of
this fully managed experience and since
Cloud workstations can run inside the
same network as your other resources
you don't need to emulate services or
databases which Can Save hours by
developing and running code in your
staging environment Cloud workstations
enables consistent developer definitions
among developers with all environments
defined via containers
fixing the well it works on my machine
problem
increasing developer velocity is
incomplete without having the right
security controls in place for remote
Developers
this is why Cloud workstations has
Enterprise grade security requirements
built right in
this starts with VPC service controls
where you can limit developer access to
sensitive areas you can update or patch
your environments so that developers get
the most up-to-date version
and you can also use a fully private
Gateway so that only trusted users
within your network have Dev access
Cloud workstations can provide security
capabilities as you code which can be
extended to other parts of your software
supply chain from build dependency
management to deployment
on the product side we are taking those
efforts to the next level with the
launch of software delivery Shield
software delivery Shield provides a
fully managed end-to-end software supply
chain security
this starts with the IDE and includes CI
CD pipelines deploy time policies and
runtime security posture
so while you're focused on writing code
software delivery Shield or SDS is
helping to make sure your organization's
security policy is consistently enforced
across the software delivery process
enabling you to develop faster
specifically SDS adds new security
capabilities in four major areas
first to shift left into the IDE we are
launching Cloud code Source protect
a private preview IDE extension which
helps you better understand open source
vulnerabilities and licenses to go
faster by avoiding costly and
frustrating rework down the road
second when it comes to securing
dependencies we're excited to announce
our assured open source software service
it scans for known vulnerabilities
analyze and fuzz tests over 250 packages
across Java and python
these packages are built using Google
secured pipelines to help external
dependency risks and come with
remediation slas
third
SDS helps secure CI CD with Cloud build
which now supports salsa level 3.
for those unfamiliar salsa is an
emerging standard that incorporates best
practices for software supply chain
integrity
Cloud build provides verifiable build
provenance to help you trace a binary to
its source and build process to prevent
tampering improve the artifact you're
using is legit
fun fact Providence is not just
available for containers but for Java
Maven packages as well
lastly SDS can extend security
protection into Cloud run and gke
Cloud run security panel now includes
software supply chain security insights
this provides information such as salsa
level on the running container images
build provenance and service
vulnerabilities
to help protect kubernetes workloads gke
security posture management provides
opinionated foundational guidance into
your gke clusters
we do this by providing detailed
security assessments actionable
remediation advice and scanning for OS
vulnerabilities in your running images
we're integrating the platform to
further help drive speed and efficiency
for instance
Cloud deploy can make continuous
delivery for cloud run much simpler
promote from pre-prod to prod conduct
rollbacks and manage gate promotion
approvals in a cohesive and intuitive
interface
with the new Cloud run Integrations you
can connect Cloud run with Google cloud
services fast
for example configuring domains with a
load balancer or connecting to a redis
cache is now as easy as a single click
and by the way we have more scenarios on
the way
with these enhancements you no longer
need to be an expert in scaling securing
or managing your pipelines or connecting
to other Google cloud services we've
also been focused on helping remove
barriers across our data platform
allowing developers to build data-driven
applications faster
after all data often Powers the most
impactful experiences
we're providing integration with vertex
AI our AIML platform
this enables inferencing directly within
the database transaction
in addition we're announcing in preview
spanner integration with vertex AI
this integration allows data scientists
to build their models easily in vertex
AI and developers to access those models
using the SQL query language
it's a great time to be a developer
because software is enabling businesses
to reimagine how they're providing more
engaging experiences
in doing this with the peace of mind
that security is embedded at every step
of the way and everything I just
described was designed to help you focus
on what you love writing code fast
we're excited to create this future
together thanks for joining us
[Music]